and first of all the government
announced today that uk startups
focusing on sustainable technology have
attracted more than two billion pounds
of investment this year from renewable
energy to carbon-free flying taxis
innovation is helping drive that
transition to net zero but is it enough
uh well let's talk about this then laura
young a record amount of money for these
so-called impact startups that's only
got to be good news isn't it
i think it's really great news that
we're beginning to see so much
investment in sustainable business i
think it's important that we're
beginning to move all sectors towards
this the one thing i worry about though
when we talk about green tech is that we
often try and think about how we can
design our way out of the climate crisis
when often we need to also be having a
conversation about less consumption and
actually returning backwards to ways
that are less damaging for the planet i
think some of the businesses that you
mentioned earlier are great i'm wearing
some kind of secondhand fashion so i
know that's one i've benefited from
myself but i do worry when we think
about flying taxis or more electric cars
and more batteries that we maybe miss a
conversation of how we can make things
like public transport more affordable
and accessible because that's just as
important a climate solution as well as
advancing in a technological way and so
i just really hope that some of the
money also goes towards advancing tech
wise the systems that we already have
and not just thinking about new design
solutions that are kind of really
futuristic and fun
stu roberts do you agree with that does
there need to be more of a joined up
conversation and more of a focus on
reducing consumption rather than relying
on on new wizzy tech ideas
yeah i think look it's a it's a
combination of both and for me i see
some really exciting technology
solutions in agriculture whether that be
feed additives that can reduce methane
uh whether that be methane tractors or
or solar-powered robots to weed crops i
think that's all really exciting stuff
but for me it's also about
not just looking at tech to solve this
there's a consumption side as laura said
but it's also about looking at things
like particularly in agriculture carbon
sequestration so how can we take that
carbon out of the atmosphere through our
soils through our grassland so tech it
can be exciting uh it could be fun uh
but but equally it's not the sole
solution and but isn't there an issue
laura of keeping people on side some of
these exciting innovative ideas will
allow people to carry on their lives as
they were before but in a greener way
doesn't doesn't technology help them do
that and you've got to keep the public
committed
i would maybe worry that we're really
struggling to actually live the way that
we currently live at a sustainable rate
and i'm not really sure green tech will
be the solution for that actually i
would love to see this investment into
ways that we can do things in a more
sustainable way and kind of returning
back to some of the more simpler
solutions but we can also have some
really fun tech solutions within the
systems that we already have instead of
just trying to create new industries
above the ones that we already have and
i think it's just about shifting that
that mindset and although it might not
be as fun it's still possible and it
still allows for a lot of growth and a
lot of economic growth as well
and i'm just going to remind everyone of
what john kerry said stuart he rather
controversially said that 50 of the
reductions we have to make by 2050 or
2045 are going to come from technologies
we don't yet have i mean a lot of people
disputed that figure but do you think
that governments are caught up with the
idea of being over-reliant on technology
as well
yeah i think for me it's that about that
balance so i think technology will help
us on that journey absolutely and i can
see some areas uh in agriculture where
where there will be technology in future
to solve things we don't even know about
it yet but some of it is also about
looking at just how we do things so for
me the classic is the hedgerow we can
sequester a lot more carbon in our
hedgerows by managing them slightly
different they add to our landscape but
they're maybe not quite as sexy and
exciting as some of the tech but
actually can have a
as big if not bigger impact
and those are some of the areas we've
got to spend equal amounts of resources
and time on
you